can Myanmar return to democracy a year
after the military coup public
institutions and the economy have
collapsed an international diplomatic
pressure has stalled so how long can the
Army resist giving power back to the
people this is Inside Story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program I'm
Elizabeth peranum a year ago myanmar's
transitioned to democracy ended when the
military seized power the Army has
ignored International pressure to
reinstate civilian rule the United
Nations is demanding more sanctions
against the Junta calling it a criminal
Enterprise
video was one of the first signs of the
army takeover and a memorable image of
that day a fitness instructor doing her
exercises while tanks rolled into the
capital nappy door elected leaders
including aung San tsuchi were arrested
and jailed military commander minonglang
imposed a state of emergency and
declared himself prime minister
give me
well the crew triggered some of the
biggest protests in myanmar's history
the military's response was Swift and
violent some cities held small
demonstrations on Tuesday's anniversary
but most marked the coup with silent
strikes as part of a campaign of civil
disobedience
State media say military leader
minonglang has extended the state of
emergency for another six months he's
ignored a plan by the Association of
Southeast Asian Nations so asean to
restore democracy people in Myanmar have
been speaking to our correspondent Tony
Chang
thank you
to drive around myanmar's cities
everyday life might look like it's
normal
but look a little closer roads are
closed with barriers barricaded military
positions and uniformed soldiers on the
streets you
destroy the protest
I was very afraid that's why I'm scared
to go out again
there were more protests beside my house
so I joined if I feel safe I will join
the protest
foreign
has been ravaged by covid-19 in the past
12 months the situation intensified
after the military targeted medical
workers for their involvement in
protests and a civil disobedience
movement
many were arrested others fled into
hiding
today even basic health care services
are scarce
I won't forget the day that hair workers
were arrested and treated very badly by
the army they either killed a medical
student that's why I will return to the
hospital
area
in the cities food remains plentiful but
prices have risen sharply
elsewhere supplies and production have
run dangerously low the world food
program estimates it needs to provide
food for 4 million people across Myanmar
in 2022 four times the number before the
coup
the economy has gone into freefall Banks
limit withdrawals and foreign investment
is pulling out fast many people uh lose
their jobs
and it is impacting to the uh the labor
market and also many people are jobless
but the many job Seekers are getting the
job but being picked less than normal
even basic services like trains and
buses are failing the Nationwide rail
network has ground to a halt after
workers joined the Civil Disobedience
movement and bus prices have tripled as
operators abandoned standardized rules
in my opinion if we get rid of army rule
Transport Services would go back to
normal with properly working buses and
normal ticket prices
historically the people of myanmari used
to military rule but after a decade of
progress and development the last 12
months is leaving many feeling as if
they're returning to the Past Tony Chang
Al Jazeera
well let's bring in our guests in the
Thai Capital Bangkok is Debbie stottan
founder and coordinator of alcian Burma
that's a network of organizations
working on human rights and democracy in
Myanmar in London Ronan Lee fellow at
Loughborough University in London and
author of the book myanmar's rohingya
genocide and in Vancouver and Canada we
have Yasmin ullah a rohingya human
rights activist a very warm welcome to
the program and I'll start with you miss
dottart in Bangkok given the state of
the country has the military coup been a
failure
oh Elizabeth this school has been a
tragic failure tragic for the people in
the country but definitely a failure for
the hunter senior gentleman online and
his military uh cronies certainly did
not expect the level of determination
and sustained resistance mainly from
young people and women leading this
movement they still have not been able
to gain territorial control of the
country a year after trying to cease
power and Mr Lee if we look at the
resistance that uh Miss dothard has
spoken about to the military coup and
that resistance has led to so much
violence in many parts of the country
now the departing U.N special Envoy to
Myanmar has said that the country is on
the verge of Civil War do you agree yes
I do the simple reality is is that the
Myanmar military has used every tool of
violence and oppression at its disposal
result to try and convince the people of
Myanmar to just quietly accept to
acquiesce to a military coup they've had
12 months and after 12 months they're
still not in control of the country I
mean the coup has been a disaster for
the military it's been tragic for the
people of Myanmar but this is by no
means a successful coup for the military
12 months and they still cannot embed
their coup that the question that
seriously must be asked now really is if
they can't achieve that in 12 months can
they ever and that's a call to the
International Community to the the UN
Security Council to to get involved in
this because what seems to be happening
is that the military cannot win the
people aren't prepared to let them win
understandably and but the military are
prepared to fight to the last person
standing in Myanmar to have a chance of
winning and we just simply should not
allow that to occur
and there are so many people in Myanmar
that also seem to be willing to fight to
the very last person
um Yasmin ullah in Vancouver has the
military coup I mean it has been
devastating and a disaster for most of
the people in Myanmar who are against it
but what impact has it had on the
country's ethnic minorities like the
rohingya oh wow it's it's just
Indescribable
um we've had the military targeting
um us with you know all kinds of
violence and um intents to to destroy
the entire communities for many many
decades and um this is just it's for
ethnic Community it's just another day
of being part of the ethnic communities
um just recently just within this month
alone there has been a lot of um arrest
and penalization of movements for
rohingya
um we have 200 000 people
rohingya are still stuck in
apartheid-like
um conditions in internment camps who
are not receiving the aid and you know
proper help from outside nor you know
the authorities involved and uh the
conditions have just worsened and
worsened for you know for rohingya
people
um and other ethnic communities it's
just been hell and what we're seeing
increasingly is that you know people who
are against the military coup are
joining the ranks of different ethnic
armed groups around the country and
challenging the military we've seen in
recent months the military has lost
control over territory including in chin
and rakhine states the sagang region the
Maguey division Deborah stottard how
does that impact the military's hold on
the country is how stretched is the
military right now how much pressure is
it under well the the hundred is relying
on air strikes now on civilian areas
including recently an airstrike on Lloyd
court the biggest city the state capital
of Kaya or kareni state so what has
happened is that besides launching all
stretching out all the human resources
to attack people the military has also
lost thousands of defectors
soldiers and police have defected from
the Junta because they cannot bear
what's going on and instead the military
is now recalling uh retired veterans to
active duty and forcing soldiers wives
and children to do military training
what this is telling us is that they
have locked themselves as Ronan says on
a path to fight till the last person
standing they are not willing to make
any compromise or show any mercy and
this in itself has also forced the
civilian population to realize that they
have two choices fight or flee and most
of them cannot run away so folks are
being forced to stand there stand to to
to fight back in order to guarantee
their own Survival but let's also
remember that what we are facing is the
scale of atrocity crimes and conflict
that in since September every month the
number of attacks hurting people
military attacks harming people in
Myanmar has actually been more than
Afghanistan and Syria combined that's
how serious the conflict is absolutely
thousands of civilians have been killed
around 1500 in the protests that
followed the military coup often
peaceful protests around a third of
those who were in custody and from
torture but we've had many others who've
been killed in the fighting that's been
going on in the countryside often
they're civilians Mr Lee what is it
going to take you know for the
International Community to do more we
have had the United States Britain and
Canada imposing new sanctions on
myanmar's Military after the past year
of chaos they've been blacklisting more
people who are linked to the Junta do
you see these latest round of sanctions
making any difference to what's been
happening in the country over the past
year Well sanctions that Target the
military's economic base will certainly
help but the the International Community
needs to do much more than imposed
sanctions there needs to be a global
arms embargo on Myanmar I mean the
Myanmar military should not be able
today and tomorrow and next week to
continue to buy weapons to turn on its
own people and that's the responsibility
of the United Nations security Council
and there hasn't there hasn't been a
vote on that at the security Council
it's time the USA and the UK and others
stepped up and put this to a vote at the
United Nations security Council and
let's actually work out where the
political will is for action and where
it isn't and if the problem here is that
China would threaten a veto or would
veto then this becomes China's political
problem now China won't want that
because China has a very long land
border with Myanmar it doesn't want a
catastrophe next door but it's
philosophically against intervention if
it can avoid it and it will be signaling
perhaps to others that it might feature
but I'm not sure that it will in the
current circumstances the atrocities
that we saw from the Myanmar military
during December I mean Burning Alive 31
people who were fleeing violence I mean
that was on Christmas Eve uh there was a
peaceful protest in Yangon during
December the military drove a truck at
the protesters at full speed other
instances in other parts of the country
where we've seen Collective punishment
of civilians so if there was militia
action against the military and the
military are losing quite often when the
when these militias take them on they
punish the local community by well
Burning Alive 11 people including
children I mean this this is a this is a
brutal and cruel military that should
not be in power in Myanmar and and I I
would and and there are and there are a
number of people who are saying that
there needs to be
um that they there can't be any weapons
or money being supplied to the military
Junta but who is it that is supplying
those weapons and
um money Mr Lee well China and Russia
are selling weapons among others to the
Junta I mean that they're I mean China's
a big arms supplier too the Junta Russia
as has also emerged particularly since
the coup as quite involved uh in terms
of providing arms to um to the Joint
within Myanmar I mean Russia gains uh
access to a port uh on the Bay of Bengal
because of that but Russia doesn't share
a border with Myanmar so Russia really
cares a lot lot less than China does I
don't think China wants I mean China had
indicated that it was not happy with the
fact of the coup whatever about the
situation afterwards I'm not sure China
wants that to face the potential of
years and years of catastrophe in a
country where it shares a 1500 kilometer
land border I mean people will flee
across that border and that will be a
problem for China I mean I think it's in
China's interests as much as it's in the
interests of the people of Myanmar to
resolve this as quickly as possible and
I want to talk a little just a little
bit about how we've got here you know to
this point because how much has the
international Yasmine bring you in here
now how much do you think the
international communities lack of action
so far has been reminiscent of what
happened you know the lack of of the
response or lack thereafter the 26-17
rohingya crisis when condemnation wasn't
matched with actions and how much do you
think that lack of action has
contributed to the military's decision
to launch the current coup you know
convinced that it might face
condemnation but little else from the
U.N or Western governments as Mr Lee has
been writing well there are a lot of
elements of economic interest within
Myanmar and there are very specific
Enterprises including the mehl Mec and
the military oil and gas company that
have been actually getting revenues from
the foreign investors that includes the
U.S Canada South Korea and many other
democratic nations that actually did not
halt the um the investment or revenues
flow into Myanmar military companies
doing or after 2017 genocidal campaign
so in in that case the genocide of
rohingya people has proven to be quite
profitable to the Myanmar military
because it actually did not stop foreign
companies and International Community
from investing within Myanmar from
actually you know adding on to the to
the um Power and the impunity within
within the country
um and that actually resulted in so many
different
um deterioration within uh within the
domestic
um institutions within Myanmar and that
includes you know criminal justice
system and it actually has helped
emboldened the name our military so much
that it actually you know today where
we're seeing the coup um and the cycle
of violence just never ending we have
seen in the last uh just recently uh
Debbie's thought had we've had you know
energy companies Chevron total at least
pulling their in pulling out of Myanmar
are you hopeful by those sort of uh
corporate actions do you think that they
could lead to more and lead to some more
pressure on the military given that the
military does earn a lot of revenue from
those companies well the let's face the
fact that Chevron hotel and also would
outside Australia announced their
withdrawal from the country also because
the reputational and operational risks
they were facing outweighed any benefits
or profits they could get now or in the
future and that's because the the Junta
itself has wrecked the economic
infrastructure of the company of the
country but between now and six months
ahead when they pull out when they
actually pull out they are scheduled to
hand over a couple of hundred million
dollars of Revenue to Myanmar oil and
gas Enterprise which is controlled by
the Junta and this is why we've been
advocating for uh sanctions so that
these companies are compelled to put
those revenues in a trust account
instead of handing it over to the Junta
because that money could be used to kill
more people and I just want to go back
to what Ronan Lee was saying about China
on the 28th of January the China's
representative at the U.N security
Council shocked us all by talking about
the urgency of halting violence in
Myanmar so the the Beijing is finally
admitting and that it that what is
happening in the country
does affect China and hopefully China
will will back up those concerns by not
supplying any more weapons so I think um
that the space is now there the security
Council for some type of action to be
taken and and we shouldn't be high we
shouldn't be afraid of countries
exercising the any veto on Burma Myanmar
if they do then it's time for them to
actually own their support for this
brutal Hunter instead of trying to
prevent anything from being tabled in
the first place yeah I mean it was
really really interesting for China to
make that comment saying that the there
was that urgent need to stop the
violence in Myanmar again given you know
what does that mean for its part and
again Ronan Lee
um is this the time you know to
um to strike while the iron's heart is
China's signaling that perhaps it would
will use its veto power to vote in a way
that you wouldn't expect it to at the
U.N security Council well I think when
the coup was launched the Chinese
ambassador to Myanmar made a very strong
public statement for a Chinese
Ambassador which was that the coup was
not in China's interests and that was a
strong signal at that time that that
China did not want to encourage the the
coup and was was I think pushing for
there to be a negotiated settlement that
the Chinese authorities had a very good
relationship with Onsen tsuchi and the
national league for democracy government
so they weren't keen on a coup I think
the issue though now for China is that
what they're faced with is a situation
that is a prolonged conflict within
Myanmar on its doorstep that's the
choice the choice is to continue backing
the military and accept that there'll be
a prolonged conflict because the
military won't go quietly or take action
and bring this to a head sooner and let
the people of Myanmar be the people
who'd be the ones who determine who
governs their country and the the
alternate for China is they can have
peace within Myanmar with with the
people determining who's in charge or
they can have chaos by continuing to
back the military I think it's
insightful too that those major
multinationals are announcing now that
they're withdrawing because I think in
some ways that's an indication that that
they see the writing on the wall too
they see that the military is likely to
lose and they want to be able to have a
working relationship with the new
civilian government in the future and
that's a positive sign yeah absolutely
Yasmine oh no what about asean's role in
all of this you know Myanmar is a member
do you see it playing a more effective
role in stopping the violence at the
moment
I unfortunately don't but it does not
mean that we cannot continue to engage
them
um I think there needs to be more
International pressure that mounting you
know upon asean to actually do more
especially
um because of the Thai Burma border
um and you know because of the the
airstrikes and and many many waves of
violence that have happened
there are many roles that asean can play
in at the very least ensuring that
people are actually kept safe and I want
to ask a question to Debbie starter
because she's actually in Bangkok and
Bangkok and Thailand has been the one of
the supporters you know in asean of the
of the military but while there is so
much violence along the border and you
have thousands of people crossing into
Thailand from Myanmar which Thailand
doesn't want can can you see the Thai
authorities changing their View on their
support for the military junta
I think at this point there when
we be active encouragement and pressure
for asean to get its act together and in
this case
um allowing a humanitarian Aid millions
and millions of dollars of humanitarian
Aid to flow across Thai borders towards
uh communities in urgent need in Burma
also means a potential of economic
recovery in a country that's already hit
by the covet pandemic so I think it's it
potentially is a win-win situation for
Thailand it's not in in Thailand's
interest for chaos to reign in Myanmar
because they because of the Border
situation because of the fact that
alongside this violence there's also a
covet pandemic in progress that's
actually out of control in Burma Myanmar
so it's in Thailand's interest to
actually contribute to a buffer zone a
safe buffer zone for ethnic and
displaced oh because we have seen in the
past few months is when when the
military Junta
sent does artillery fire launches
modifier on people in current state in
Kaya State On the Border areas some of
that has actually affected Thai people
of course the Thai side so yeah so I
think I think in terms of human Security
in terms of economic stability in terms
of dealing with the covet pandemic it's
actually in Thailand's interest to work
with the rest of the International
Community to ease the situation well
let's see if these countries such as
Thailand and China can work not only in
their own interests but most importantly
in the interest of the people of Myanmar
I'm afraid we have run out of time but I
want to thank all of you for this
discussion that is Debbie stottarden Lee
and Yasmine Ula and thank you too for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our Facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash AJ Inside
Story you can also join the conversation
on Twitter our handle is at AJ inside
story from me Elizabeth peranum and the
whole team here bye for now
[Music]